لم يقتصر الأمر على تشبث هذا الرجل
بغطاء محرك السيارة لمسافة 19 ميلاً ، فقد تمكن من الاتصال برقم
9-1-1 أعلى السيارة الآن ،
نعم ملكية المجتمع
من وجهة نظر صديقته السابقة وهو
يقود سيارة مرسيدس من وجهة نظر
مرور  سائق السيارة ما كنت
أفكر فيه هو أن صديقي كان هناك
رجل أسود على الزجاج الأمامي
هو مثل منتشر في جميع أنحاء غطاء المحرك
اسمه جونيور.  فرانسيس كنت خائفًا ، لقد
كنت خائفة من أن صديقته السابقة باتريشيا
هي باب قالت إنها أيضًا كانت خائفة من
الرجل النفسي الذي لن يتركه
بمفرده هذا هو الصديق السابق الذي
لن يتركني
وحدي ، ويؤكد الضابط الاثنين  اتصلت
بالشرطة عدة مرات في ذلك اليوم وحتى
توقفت عند المحطة ، لكن عندما
أرادت باتريشيا استخدام السيارة التي شاركاها ،
قفزت ابنتها جونيور على
غطاء المحرك ، وقادت السيارة بسرعة 70 ميلاً في الساعة على
الطريق السريع 95 متجهًا نحو ميامي ،
وكان لديه فرص للنزول  سيارتي
ولن ينزل من السيارة ، لذلك أشعر
أنه يعرض نفسه للخطر ، فقد استمرت المكالمة 9-1-1
لأكثر من 25 دقيقة
طمسها النوافذ ، واستمرت المكالمة في
إسقاط الاتجاهات التي أسيء التواصل معها في
النهاية ، قامت بسحب الشرطة
ألقت القبض عليها ، ووجهت لها تهمة
الإهمال اللوم ، كما أن الإنترنت
مهووس بأشياء صغيرة ،
كيف بحق الجحيم هو أن التقليب
يبقى في مكانه ، ثم كانت هناك المرأة التي
تغردت متسائلة عما إذا كانت سيارة المرسيدس قد
حصلت على غطاء محرك جديد  إنه ليس
زينة ، إنه رجل ظل
متمسكًا برومانسية محطمة وانتهى به الأمر
متشبثًا بغطاء محرك السيارة فقط راقب نفسك
وكن حذرًا من تحب جين موس سي إن إن نيويورك